FEMALE SPEAKER:
Welcome everybody.
Welcome to "Kitchen Sink."
This is our kitchen to play
in and to let Googlers really
learn how to fish.
We don't just give you fish.
We want you to
learn how to fish.
But my guest today, Ann
Cooper is the person
who really has changed the
way a very important part
of our population eats and
cooks, and that's children.
So I'd like to welcome you.
Thank you.
Thank you for doing
the class earlier.
ANN COOPER: My pleasure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And it was
delicious and simple and good,
and it's recipes
from what she cooks
for the kids in the
Boulder School District
from the Berkeley
School District.
So when I knew Ann
many years ago,
she had the moniker of being
the renegade lunch lady
because she was the only
one doing this, doing really
good, healthy,
nutritious food to kids.
And I'll have her
tell that story later.
And now, she was kind
of lamenting to me
that we can't call
her that anymore
because so many other school
districts are doing this.
She's really at the
head of this movement
to change school food around
and how our children eat.
So she's not renegade,
but what she's done
is a lot of other things,
like started a foundation.
The Food Farmer Foundation?
ANN COOPER: Food Family Farming.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Food
Family Farming Foundation.
She's got her own nonprofit.
Her daytime job, as she says,
is running the Boulder School
District and turning that
freight train around,
all the conventional
old practices
of a school district in the US.
So I'm delighted
to have you here.
Thank you.
ANN COOPER: My pleasure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
So what is the work now, Ann?
It's not being the renegade.
So many people are being you and
trying to turn things around.
What's the next step in turning
around our children's diets?
ANN COOPER: Well,
you know, I'm not
even sure we're past
the crawling point yet.
There's 113,000 schools in
this country, 14,000 school
districts.
So there's so many schools
and so many school districts.
And they have no
money, and they're
under the USDA guidelines.
So it's really baby
steps to make changes.
And there are
school districts all
across the country
that are making them,
but it's really slow
and really hard.
And I just heard that there's
four daycares at Google,
and of course Google
has amazing food,
but most school districts
run on $1.20 for food cost,
which is a quarter
of a venti coffee.
So the idea that we would try
and feed our kids healthy food
on $1.20 or $1.25 is
of course ridiculous.
So if we're going to
really make these changes,
we need more money
in the system.
We need better
food in the system.
We need facilities
for people to cook in.
And we need training
for the cooks,
and we need marketing
for the kids.
I've already heard,
my kid won't eat.
That's what every parent
says, is my kid won't eat,
fill in the blank.
So in all of these ways,
we need to make changes.
But to just build on what Olivia
said, I have three day jobs.
I'm the director of nutrition
services in Boulder Valley
School District.
We do about 11,000 meals a day.
And everything's
cooked from scratch
or to our specifications.
We have salad bars in
every school, pre-K to 12.
We have organic milk, hormone
and antiobotic free beef
and chicken, only whole
grains, I mean on and on.
But five years later, it's
super hard to do that.
And before I was in
Boulder, I was in Berkeley.
So that kind of
work is really hard.
My foundation does three things.
One, we work in conjunction
with the first lady's
Let's Move campaign.
We have Let's Move
salad bars to schools.
And we raised about
$8 and 1/2 million
putting salad bars in schools
all across the country.
I think we have
about 3,400 right
now, which is really great.
And we have
thelunchbox.org, which
is our web portal that has all
free information for school
districts all across the country
to make that change from how
we process to scratch cooked.
And then we have a
breakfast project as well.
So we have all that, and I
also have a consulting company
that actually does technical
assistance for school districts
that are really trying
to make the change.
Most recently, we
were in Baltimore
for a year working on
that school district,
and now we're going to be doing
some more work in California.
So a lot of stuff is going on.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Basically, though, if it
has to do with what
most of these people
are here to hear about,
which is how do I
get my kid to eat more
vegetables, fill in the blank?
And why is it you can do it,
and they can't do it at home?
Or they're fighting
more at home?
ANN COOPER: Well,
first of all, if there
is better food in schools,
it becomes easier at home.
I mean, that's
absolutely critical.
I mean, if every day
your kid goes to school
and has choices off of a salad
bar that has 20 items on it,
and because there's choice,
they will make their own palette
of flavors that
they like or palette
of colors that they like.
I mean, that's really,
really helpful.
But one of the big issues
really is that one of-- what's
the first word a child learns?
Well maybe mama, maybe
dada, and then no.
Right?
And they're saying
no to whatever
is on that spoon
going in their mouth.
And so we teach our kids
from the very earliest age
that their place of
power is no over what
you're putting in their mouth.
And then, of course, there's
no for all these other things.
But because we are doing it to
them, we're handing it to them,
we're having them eat it.
So they've learned that.
So when parents tell me, my
kids don't eat x, y, or z,
and I bring them
into the kitchens
and say stand behind
the window and watch
your kid eat all of this stuff.
And they go, no, my
kid won't eat that.
I'm going, is that your child?
And it's because we
give them choices.
It's because they are not
fighting with their parents
and having a win or lose
kind of game going on.
We take the power away, and
we just give them the choices.
And there's this funny thing
that's happened in America,
and it's happened in
just 40 or 50 years.
40 or 50 years ago,
there wasn't kids' food.
40 or 50 years ago, 55 years
ago, there wasn't McDonald's.
There wasn't Burger King.
65 years ago was when
the National School Lunch
program started.
Chicken nuggets aren't that old.
So it's this idea that
there's kids' food.
And I happened to be able
to go to China with Olivia
a number of years ago,
and her great-aunt--
whether it's an aunt or
not-- we had this banquet
that she was overseeing.
You look at the
food, and there's
chicken heads and
whatever was on the table.
And so I asked through
Olivia, what about kids' food?
And she said, what?
There's not even a
concept of kids' food.
She thought, what do
you mean, kids' food?
And so this idea that kids
get to have their own food,
and that it should be colors
or flavor, taco something
cereals, or Fruit Loops
cereals, or chicken nuggets that
are in the shape of hearts,
diamonds, and Flipper.
I mean, all of
this is marketing.
And so big companies are
spending $17 to $20 billion
a year marketing these
non-nutrient foods to kids.
And then all of us are
sitting there going, well,
how do we get the
kids to eat broccoli
if what's being marketed to them
is this unhealthy junk that's
supposed to be fun food,
that is kids' food?
It's something that the
kids think is their own.
And that becomes
their choice then,
and that becomes the
things that they're
drawing a line in the sand.
And I only eat chicken nuggets.
I only eat tater tots.
I only eat white bread or rice
or pasta or fill in the blank.
Because that's the
thing they get to have.
So the way we work against
that in our school district
is we have 200 to
300 events a year.
So we do tastings and
Iron Chef competitions,
and we do rainbow days where
the kids go to the salad bar
and have to get four
colors off the rainbow,
and they get a sticker.
So they get stickers if they
eat all the different colors
of the rainbow and all the
flavors that go with that.
So we really try and
make it educational,
and we really try and
make it all about choice.
And that helps.
But there is no kid food
in our district at all.
So we don't have chicken nuggets
or french fries or tater tots.
We make our own french fries.
We serve them once
or twice a month.
But nothing processed.
And kids eat the food.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
And then is there
a way to translate it for home?
I mean, if I go home and I have
half an hour to make dinner,
I'm not going to give
my kid five choices.
ANN COOPER: You would be
surprised how many families
end up being short order cooks.
And I think that that's
part of the problem.
I mean, I think if we
as adults, if we just
say-- when we go
home to make dinner,
if we're not cooking a
different thing for every person
in the family, if we say
this is what's dinner,
no child is going to
starve themselves to death.
Because I've never
heard of a child
starving to death
because of lack
of a chicken nugget
or a tater tot.
But as soon as we
continually decide
that we are going to be short
order cooks, then again,
that's what happens.
Then we are becoming
short order cooks,
and then we give everybody
their own little thing,
whatever it is they want.
And all of a sudden,
then you guys
go home from work every
day pulling our hair out
because this kid only eats this
and this kid only eats this,
and this kid only eats this.
And it becomes this
nightmare to live with.
I mean, I know parents
tell me this all the time
how hard it is.
But I think there are ways
around it around the kitchen
table as well.
I mean, I think that
the idea that we really
involve kids in the process.
So go shopping with your kids.
And I understand how
much of a nightmare
it is to take kids shopping.
I get it.
So you don't do it
every day or anything.
You go to the farmer's market.
We're here in California
right this minute.
There's farmers markets
every single day of the week
somewhere.
When you go to the
farmer's market
with the kids,
when you have time,
and you let them pick out
something they've never had.
And say, OK, every week,
one new thing, and we're
going to cook it together,
and you just have to try it.
Or let them grow something.
Gardens are incredible.
Every kid that would
never eat arugula,
when they pick that
arugula, they'll eat it.
When they see the carrot in
the dirt, and they'll eat it.
And they see all of a
sudden it tastes so sweet,
and it's so amazing.
So you take kids shopping.
Cook with kids.
Grow with kids.
Have them involved
in the process.
I was with some
people last night
that say one of things
they do is they--
and this is a little older than
maybe the preschool kids here--
but in middle school, with
their middle school kids,
they may have them make
the menu once a week.
So they get to choose.
It has to be healthy.
Here's the deal.
You have to have a fruit or
a vegetable, whatever it is.
But you make the menu,
and I'll help you cook it.
And then we'll all
eat it together.
And everybody has their turn of
when they get to make the menu.
Maybe it's not once a week.
Maybe it's once a
month, whatever.
The other thing that's
really important
is sitting down at the
dinner table with your kids.
Turning off the TV, the
iPhone, the iPad, the computer,
everything.
Take a moratorium on all
things digital for 45 minutes
and sit down with your
child or children and family
as many times of
the week as you can.
It's not going to be every
night, but as many times as you
can, as a full family, and
take that time to eat together.
It solves so many problems.
And when all of a sudden, meal
time becomes something special,
then it's something that then
becomes part of a core value.
We now live in a country where
one out of every four meals
is actually eaten in a car.
We've made cars our
dining rooms in America.
One out of every
four meals is fast
food, and one out of
every four meals in front
of a blue screen-- iPhone, iPad,
or in Google world, Android.
But that's what we do.
And so we've taken away
this core value of food,
and it changes things.
It really changes the dynamic.
And we need to get that back.
We need to find
our kitchens again.
We need to cook
again, turn off the TV
and get rid of all the blue
screens for one hour a day.
Or even 45 minutes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But there were
stories, I heard some of them,
from early days when
you were at Berkeley.
So the background is
Alice Waters in Berkeley
heard about what Ann was doing
at a private school called
Ross, and said you're
coming to Berkeley choose
to turn this freight
train around.
And she did.
But what happened
in the early days?
Tell us some stories.
ANN COOPER: Well, yeah.
There's some crazy
stories, including
when I went to Boulder as well.
But one of the first things that
happened even before I got out
here to California,
at the Ross School.
The Ross School was a very
well-funded private school
in New York, in East Hampton.
And I think the first or
second year we were there,
I had a bunch of fourth
graders march in.
It was all girls at that point.
It wasn't co-ed.
March into the cafeteria,
sit down on the floor,
and say, Miss Cooper,
we're on strike.
We hate your food.
And they all sat down.
I felt like cheering.
But I know I wasn't-- that
wasn't what was supposed
to happen.
So I didn't cheer.
I sat down on the floor
with them, and I said,
what's going on?
We hate your grilled
cheese sandwiches.
Well, how can you hate the
grilled cheese sandwiches?
The bread is yucky.
It's brown.
The cheese isn't orange.
So of course it was
in New York, and it
was beautiful white cheddar,
and we made the bread ourselves.
So we started a cooking
class for the girls.
We had a cheese tasting.
We let them make
their own bread.
They came up with a ratio on the
bread that met our guidelines.
And all of a sudden, they
had a grilled cheese sandwich
that was as good
as the other one.
Different, 50 something percent
whole grain instead of 100%.
I was fine with that.
We switched from white
cheddar to orange cheddar.
I was OK with that.
A little annatto
never hurt anybody.
But that was their sandwich.
So the next year,
these young girls
are bringing the new girls into
the cafeteria, and they said,
oh my god.
You guys have it
so much luckier.
We fixed everything.
The food is so much
better here now.
So they liked to have taken
total ownership over it.
When I got to
Berkeley at King, this
is before the new kitchen was
built over there at King Middle
School, the kids
actually went on strike
and were throwing their food
against the side of the school.
So they would just
take their food,
and they would walk outside,
and there were bouncing it
off the side of the school.
So after lunch, there's
this whole pile of food.
So we did have that whole
discussion about, again,
what was wrong.
What do you want to change?
How can you fix it?
How can we work on it together?
And eventually, all these years
later, the Berkeley School food
is still unbelievable
and amazing.
And we had some of the same
things happened in Boulder.
But I've been there
five years now,
and participation over
the last three years
has gone up 6%, 6%, and 7%.
So it works.
It just takes time.
That's the other thing.
We didn't become a nation
of obese people overnight.
We're not going to
change overnight.
We didn't change children's
palates to be really invested
in high salt, high fat,
high sugar overnight.
So we're not going to turn that
train around overnight either.
So you just have to keep
walking down the road of going,
OK, this is what it is.
And it's going to be this way
tomorrow and the next day.
So what's it going to
take to get used to it?
FEMALE SPEAKER: So it's
about ownership for the kids.
ANN COOPER: It's about
ownership for the kids.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But
what about the parents?
I hear you had some threats.
ANN COOPER: I had death threats.
I had actual, written
death threats from parents.
In Berkeley and in Boulder, as
a matter of fact-- in Berkeley,
the death threats
included, I hope
somebody runs you
off the Bay Bridge.
This was, of course,
the old Bay Bridge.
And then when I
got to Boulder, it
was I hope somebody
just runs you
all the way back to California,
where you weird people belong.
Of course, here I
am the weird person.
But parents don't want
to be told what to do.
Kids don't want to
be told what to do.
I had parents going,
whoa re you to take away
our kids' chicken nuggets?
And who are you are tell us that
we can't have chocolate milk?
And who are you to
decide what's healthy?
And my answer to
all of those things
is that schools take a higher
bar and a higher ground.
Schools are drug-free zones.
And parents may allow their
kids to smoke pot at home,
but schools are drug-free
zones, and schools
are alcohol-free zones.
Parents of high
school kids might
let their kids have a little
bit of wine at home or beer
or something.
But at schools, we say no.
And in the same way, we
as adults and caregivers
and educators have to take
that higher bar and say,
this is an educational place.
And whether tacitly or
implicitly, if we allow things
that we don't believe are in
the best interest of the child,
they become part of the culture.
So we have to make
those changes.
One of the things we work on a
lot now is educating parents.
So we do cooking classes.
We do quarterly newsletters.
I go to PTA and PTO meetings.
We do tastings for parents.
So we do all that stuff as well.
Because parents
have to be invested
in the change, as
well as the kids.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What are
some data points you have?
You're saying you have
growth, 6%, 6%, 7%.
Anything about
children's health?
their performance?
ANN COOPER: Here's the
thing about evaluation.
It's really, really expensive.
So we did an
evaluation in Berkeley.
And for half a million
dollars, here's
what I was able to find out.
Our kids that ate school lunch
ate three times more vegetables
than kids that brought
their lunch from home.
And not fruit, vegetables.
And that's really important,
because you can easily
get kids to eat fruit
because it's basically sugar.
But vegetables.
So most parents in
Berkeley would think, oh,
my kid's going to eat
healthier if I pack them lunch.
But what the evaluation
showed is actually no.
The kid's going to eat healthier
if they eat school lunch
because our school
lunch was healthy,
and because we had salad bars.
And that our kids ate
less sugar at home
because there was basically
no sugar in school.
So that's what we found out
for half a million dollars,
and that was great.
But it was not
able to do anything
about baseline wellness
or academic performance.
I think that there is-- Arkansas
is doing BMI, body mass index,
with every child in the state
that's in their K-12 program.
That should, in a few years,
have some kind of results.
But what I can tell
you anecdotally
is that it really
makes a difference.
What we see when we
change food in schools
is less absenteeism,
less tardiness, less
behavioral problems.
Those things we know.
And we also know that
hungry kids can't think
and malnourished
kids can't learn.
So we need to have kids fed.
But I think even more
important for Googlers
than that, or just as important,
is many people around Google
can probably afford to
feed their kids well.
But they're going to school with
people who may not be able to.
And every teacher
will tell you, they
have to teach to the
bottom third of the class.
It's just that's
what they have to do.
So if there's behavioral
problems in a class,
it doesn't matter how well
you're feeding your child.
If the next person is
not, and especially
if those are kids from
underprivileged homes,
then your child is not
getting the education
that you would like them
to get because there's
kids that are hungry or
malnourished in that classroom
who can't behave
and who can't think.
And your child may be
being taught down to.
So it's really important
to understand it's not just
your child, because your child
is part of a whole class.
And every child in
that class ends up
being part of the
educational model.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What about
some success anecdotes?
ANN COOPER: We see
tremendous success.
I will tell you that I'm
going to speak to Congress
in just a few weeks at
a congressional hearing
because these kind of
issues have made it
all the way up to the top.
I've done events
with Michelle Obama,
and she's been an amazing
cheerleader in this.
There is foundations all
over the country that
are putting money into
school food and to salad bars
and to gardens.
We're really seeing
the USDA make
tremendous positive change.
I mean, the National
School Lunch program,
even though it's
really imperfect,
is still feeding kids better
now than it maybe ever
has in its existence.
And if school districts
would actually
start living up to
the letter of the law,
and if our Congress
people would stop
messing with the
guidelines, then we
would see the food
get better and better.
I mean, the USDA said that
pizza shouldn't be a vegetable.
Now, I don't know if
any of you know this,
but pizza's still considered
a vegetable in schools.
And I'm pretty sure that pizza
doesn't grow out of the earth.
And why is this
considered a vegetable?
It's because one
tablespoon of tomato paste
is considered a
vegetable equivalent.
And so the lobbyists
got to Congress people--
and this is the frozen
food and tomato lobbyists
and the pizza lobbyists--
got to Congress
and convinced Congress
that the world was
going to go bankrupt if
we didn't consider pizza
a vegetable.
And the USDA in
the guidelines said
that you could only serve
starchy vegetables like corn
and potatoes twice a
week, a half a cup each.
And the potato lobby got to
Congress, and the frozen food
lobby, and got them
to turn that around.
So potatoes or
french fries can be
served as a vegetable
five days a week.
So you could actually serve
whole grain chicken nuggets,
chocolate milk with high
fructose corn syrup,
and french fries
as a complete meal
today under the guidelines.
Now, it's certainly not
the intent of the law.
But because Congress
wouldn't back up the USDA,
we ended up in that place.
So one of things we
all can do is really
think when we vote, in
congressional elections,
that the people who run
school food is the USDA.
But Congress
allocates the money.
So they get to actually pull
punches and make changes
in the program because
they hold all the cards.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So you can do
whole wheat chicken nuggets,
chocolate milk, and french
fries for $1.20 per kid?
ANN COOPER: Well, yes, you can.
But you're going to get
pretty crappy chicken
nuggets for that.
But we don't serve
chicken nuggets,
so I don't know too
much about them.
I've never eaten one.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So how much
are you spending per kid?
ANN COOPER: I'm spending in
Boulder about $1.20 on average
for the food.
The reimbursement rate from the
federal government is $2.96.
So that's what all
lunch ladies like
myself get to feed
a child is $2.96.
But that includes payroll and
overhead and trucks to deliver
and knives and cutting
boards and every piece
of the whole department.
So most school districts spend
about a third of that on food,
or around $1, $1.20 for
good school districts.
But LA spends $0.76, and
they've been very proud
of that for years.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
But you are getting
them organic, local
vegetables on most days.
ANN COOPER: Well, not
always organic vegetables.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
No chocolate milk.
ANN COOPER: But there
is no chocolate milk.
And we do have hormone and
antibiotic free hamburgers
and ground beef and chicken,
and I have organic milk.
But we work super
hard at procurement.
We working really hard at trying
to control inventory costs,
and to control waste, and
to cook as much from scratch
as possible so that we really
can keep our costs down.
But it's hard.
It's really hard.
A typical lunch here at Google
costs four or five times
what we're spending for an
entire week of our kids' meals.
And we in America think
nothing of spending
$3, $4, $5 on coffee,
$5, $6, $7 on beer,
$8, $9, $10, $15 in San
Francisco or probably
here as well, $18
on a glass of wine.
So we think, as adults, nothing
of spending 3, 5, 10, 15 times
on a sometimes daily
adult beverage,
as we do to feed a kid.
And I think that that
really needs to change.
We need to understand that our
choices as far as how we fund
education and school food
really makes a difference.
And makes a difference
for your kids
at home and at school and
their ability to learn.
And so it's super important.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Talk
about your foundation.
Why did you do it,
and what does it do?
ANN COOPER: I don't
know how I ever
came to have a foundation
around school food.
I was like, I'm such
an unlikely advocate
to be doing anything
with school food.
I was a white tablecloth
kind of crazy celebrity chef,
and never knew what kids ate.
My worst nightmare
is when somebody
from the front of the house came
running into the kitchen going,
chef, chef, there's a
screaming child on table 19.
What do I do?
And I'd say, ask them to leave.
Why are they in my restaurant?
But here I am, and I did start
a foundation four years ago now.
And the foundation was trying
to put together a toolbox.
Everyone would ask
me, are you going
to come to our
school district next?
Somebody earlier today said,
oh, San Jose really needs you.
And every place I go, they
say, oh, we really need you.
I get an email
today, oh, can you
come to Philadelphia,
Pittsburgh?
And of course I
can't clone myself.
So I decided what
we needed to do
is develop all the tools a
school district would need
to be able to go from highly
processed to scratch cooked.
Well, I originally
actually envisioned it
as a physical
toolbox 10 years ago
when I started
thinking about it.
Then shortly after that, I
said oh, no, it of course
needs to be digital.
Even 10, 12 years
ago, the reality
of the digital world we live
in today was very different.
But anyhow, it became digital.
I started a foundation.
And we did the three
things I told you about,
the lunch box and Let's
Move salad bars to schools.
And we have a breakfast program
and a few other programs
as well.
But now what we're doing is
the USDA guidelines change.
So we got a big grant to
overhaul the entire website, so
everything.
And they really only change
once every 10 or 20 years.
So we overhaul
everything so we would
be able to meet the new
guidelines going forward
for many, many, many,
many years to come.
We're also relaunching
the website,
relaunching the foundation, and
working with a lot of partners
to do that.
And I'm really excited
about all of that.
Because as we move
forward, I really
hope that we can change how
we feed every kid in America,
that it shouldn't be just
private schools or rich schools
that can feed kids well.
I mean, it ought
to be a birthright
that every child in America gets
good healthy food in school,
and that no child is hungry.
I mean, that's what
everybody wants.
And we're sitting
here at Google.
And just the amount and
variety and quality of food
we have here.
And then you think that
you go a few miles away
to a typical school, and go look
and see what they're eating.
We need to change that.
So that's what we hope to do.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Very inspiring.
So any questions from the floor?
AUDIENCE: So I wonder if you
know who particular in Congress
introduced legislation
or introduced
the line item, whatever it was,
to say pizza was a vegetable,
and maybe they'd like
some more attention.
ANN COOPER: Pizza was-- it's
been a vegetable for decades.
But the USDA had taken
it out of the new ruling
so it wouldn't be
allowed anymore.
And I don't know who
in Congress was really
forcing that the other way.
I will tell you that a
congressperson from Maine
and a congressperson
from Colorado
were the two people that made
sure that french fries could
stay in every single day and
be served as a vegetable.
So it's hard.
It's all about money.
We serve about 8
billion meals a year
in the National
School Lunch program,
and it costs about $12 billion.
Oh, that's just
lunch is $12 billion.
So it probably costs
about $15 billion.
That's a lot of money.
There's a lot of profit.
And so a lot of
people could get hurt
if we said we're going to do
things a little different.
And so there's tremendous
pushback from the industry.
AUDIENCE: If your
school district's
not focused on this, what
do you think the best
way is to get them
focused on it?
ANN COOPER: Every school
district in America since 2006
had to have a wellness
policy put in place.
Most of them have languished
on some administrative shelf.
But now, as of two years
ago, every school district
has to update them and have
them re-approved by the USDA
every three years during
their recertification.
So the first thing you do
is find the wellness policy,
which is probably-- well, you
guys all work at Google, so you
could probably figure this out,
but Google wellness policies
for your school district.
And then you'll find some
place on the website,
and you might have to dig, where
this wellness policy resides.
And they may not actually
even have it on the website,
but it's probably in the minutes
of the board meeting somewhere.
So find it.
Then go to your child's
school and actually eat lunch.
Then find a whole
bunch of moms and dads
that think like you do
and go to the school board
and say, OK, here's
the wellness policy.
And either it says nothing
about healthy food,
and you go, OK, so
this needs to change.
Or it talks all about
the healthy food,
and you can have a big,
poster-sized picture
of whatever it is you saw
on your kid's plate that day
and go, OK.
Or better yet, bring
the food with you.
And then go, we really
wanted this to change.
We live in a democracy.
And school boards are actually
not in every single place,
but in most places in
America, they're voted in.
They're voted in
by the electorate.
There are some places
where they're appointed,
but mostly they're voted in.
And superintendents
are basically
hired by the school board.
So the superintendent
and the school board
hold all the cards
around school food.
So if you want it
to change, you need
to get the school board to tell
the superintendent that better
food is really important.
And that's what you
want for your kids.
And eventually they'll listen.
Or vote them out and find
someone who will listen.
I know cities that
have actually made it
such a big, important thing
that school board members would
actually have to run
on healthy school food
as part of their
platform to get elected.
AUDIENCE: So how
much of an emphasis--
you talked about organic foods,
and I'm wondering-- because I
remember one time I was
at a farmer's market,
and there were two stands,
and one was organic.
The other was not organic,
and the price was obviously
a lot less for the non-organic.
And I said, why
isn't yours organic?
Do you use pesticides?
They were like, no.
What is it?
They go, we use some fertilizer,
so we can't say it's organic.
But for the privilege
of that, you
get to pay whatever
additional premium.
So it seems like
in a lot of cases,
going for the organic really
isn't actually that beneficial.
So how discriminating
are you in terms
of what you're trying
to do as organic
and what you recognize really
because plants are making
their own toxins
internally all the time.
That's how they
defend themselves.
ANN COOPER: So I
absolutely agree.
What we say is local first.
And the closer I am to the
source, if I know the farmer,
then that's what's
the most important.
If I know the
farmer, and they say
we're practicing IPM,
Integrated Pest Management,
or we're practicing
organic practices,
but we have a potato beetle
problem, and we are once a year
spraying something, I
don't know what, on it.
But it's well before harvest,
and we've had it tested.
So what's important
to me is that I
have an honest and open and
transparent relationship
with the person who is producing
the food for our children.
And it's not always organic.
I can't afford all organic.
But to your point, it's not
always the best alternative,
although we need to
have less chemicals
on our food and our
children's food.
So it's always a balance.
But for me, local
always comes first.
And the further away from
me it is-- like bananas,
for instance, which
I don't actually
think we're even
going to-- I think
we're going to stop serving
them altogether finally.
I've been trying, but finally
I think I've made the decision.
But organic bananas
were important
because they came from
far away, and bananas
are one of the most
chemically laden pieces
of produce in the world.
So distance and
transparency and knowledge
make a huge difference.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's interesting
that you spoke about
choice, and that choice
is an important
part of the meal.
Because I think I always
made the assumption
that choice complicates
the decision,
and so just eat what's
been put in front of you.
And so I'd like
to hear more about
how choice has helped children.
ANN COOPER: So here's the deal.
When I say choice, I don't think
there should be 10 entrees.
You go into high
schools, and they say,
oh, the kids need
mini-marts, or the kids
need seven kinds of fast food.
That's ridiculous.
But when I say choice, when
you look at a salad bar,
and there may be seven
kinds of vegetables,
and we usually have eight kinds
of vegetables, both animal
and vegetable protein,
some kind of dairy,
and something like hummus
or something like that.
So those are the kind of
choices, teaching children
that you can have-- there's
four vegetables on the table.
You can have any
two of them today.
I think that that's
the kind of choice.
Or going to the grocery
store and saying,
pick out something you want
from the vegetable aisle,
something you've never
had from the vegetable
aisle or the farmer's market,
and we'll make it together,
or something like that.
So I don't mean 10
kinds of entree choices,
like you often see
here at Google,
because I don't think
that's realistic.
And I don't support schools
having those kind of choices.
But it's more around small
choice, like salad bars,
or a couple kinds of vegetable.
So we do things like that.
AUDIENCE: And with the
vegetable consumption
that you're seeing in children
increase in their school
lunch-- is that typically
tied to the salad bar,
or are cooked vegetables
also being consumed?
ANN COOPER: Both.
But in a school food setting,
the largest percentage
of our produce is
on the salad bars.
Because it's very hard,
in a school setting,
to actually serve
cooked vegetables well.
So I'll take broccoli
as a perfect example.
I can have the most beautiful
steamed, shocked, chilled,
bright green broccoli that comes
out of our production kitchens.
Goes out to be reheated,
because it's a cook chill
operation, at the site, and I
guarantee you nine times out
of 10, they will turn
it into brown mush.
And most sites don't have the
capacity to cook that from raw.
There are some vegetables
that transport really well.
Roasted broccoli,
roasted cauliflower,
roasted carrots, things like
that transport really well.
But because raw vegetables
transport really well,
and because for most kids, if
you can get them to eat raw,
cooked is actually easier.
So it's sort of a little
harder to go backwards
because the cooked is sweeter
than the raw is oftentimes.
That's what we see.
But we saw in Boulder, we went
from $70,000 worth of produce
to $500,000 worth of produce in
three years without much waste.
It's pretty amazing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] my child
won't eat question as much
as when other children
are eating things,
and it becomes harder.
Five friends have Lay's
potato chips, and they don't.
I'm sure you see that
[INAUDIBLE] schools.
So are the children
making health--
do you see the children
making healthier decisions
on their own, given
that ultimately they
have the chicken nuggets
in front of them too?
ANN COOPER: Well, they don't.
So that's the thing.
AUDIENCE: Oh right, but
like a friend from home.
I'm sure they must.
ANN COOPER: Actually,
I have not seen
kids bring chicken
nuggets from home.
But they do bring things like
Lunchables or stuff like that.
I don't see much trading between
kids who bring their lunch
and buy their lunch.
What I see is kids
that bring their lunch
trading back and forth.
The kids who get
hot lunch actually
have a hot meal and salad.
And so there's not that kind
of trading you see with the kid
next to you that has the
Cheetos or whatever it is.
So I don't know.
But I think that
the more kids that
are eating, if the
majority of the kids
are getting hot lunch, then
that problem kind of goes away.
But it's got to start with that
the food is good for parents
to want their kids to eat,
actually eat hot lunch.
So that's the problem.
But to your point,
I mean, I think
that in the schools
where we have
a high proportion of parents
who pack their kids' lunch,
we go to the PTAs and talk
about what's in the lunches.
We have schools that have
banned candy, banned sugar
drinks and stuff like that.
And so that kind of
stuff really helps.
And that can all be in
the wellness policy.
You can actually write
a wellness policy
that says candy or
sugar-added beverages aren't
allowed in school.
Just say, that's it.
Not allowed.
And parents can do that.
AUDIENCE: My
take-away is parents
need to take
responsibility, hopefully
the other parents can make
this district continue
to raise awareness.
But is anything
top-down happening
because $2 [INAUDIBLE]
low budget.
Can the school give
them more budget?
How can we push on that?
ANN COOPER: The school
doesn't have the money.
But the government has
the money, both the state
and the federal government.
In California, the state
actually gives school
districts, I think it's
$0.19 or $0.20 per lunch.
So the state of California
actually does supplement.
Many states do not.
We need to push on the
federal government.
That's where the push
really needs to be.
And that's a policy issue.
And I think we really
need to take that on.
And I'm going to be doing
some work with Google
over the coming year, maybe two.
And I think that one of
the things that we could
try and work on is, how
do we make that push?
How do we use Googlers
and Google's influence
to make-- if this
is something that's
important to many
people, how do we start
to make the change
in the upper levels?
So there is some of
that top-down change.
Because, at the end
of the day, it's
a government-funded program
that our tax dollars pay for.
So we should really get
to make those changes.
But a lot of people don't
want to see their taxes go up.
But it's not even so much
about taxes going up.
Like right now, the National
School Lunch program,
just lunch, costs about
$12 billion a year.
And I think it should double.
And people go,
well, where are we
going to get that kind of money?
But just two diseases,
diabetes and obesity,
cost us $260 billion a year,
which is $5 billion a week.
The wars that we're not in cost
us about $3 billion a week.
So it wouldn't take
much to actually put
a whole lot more
money into the system.
But it really takes all of us.
If we all just did one
thing and got everyone else,
and we knew to do one thing
and really said, OK, we're
going to do one thing
to make this change,
then over time,
slowly but surely,
we could make this our nation's
priority, instead of-- we
have a multi-trillion
dollar budget.
Who even knows what a
trillion dollars is?
And our budget is
multi-trillion.
How could we not want
to spend an extra $0.50
on our kids' lunch?
$0.50.
And that's what I
think we need to do.
It's so little.
So little money.
AUDIENCE: It's slightly
more complicated
though because of
the lobbies, right?
I mean, because you
have-- you're doing OK,
and I'm not suggesting
[INAUDIBLE].
But you're managing to
find better options.
ANN COOPER: Well, I
spend half of my time
being a grant fundraiser.
But yes, it is
really hard though.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
lobbyists that
are pushing their processed
foods as well, right?
ANN COOPER: But this
is the only country
on the planet where this
is really happening.
And it's because that we
really haven't valued food
as a nation.
And so you go to
Italy or France,
and you see they're spending
$5, $6 on their school lunch.
And when I talked to
the people in Rome
that were overseeing
816,000 meals a day in Rome.
I said, how can you afford--
it was four euros at the time--
how could you afford
the four euros?
And she looked at me
and said, four euros
for lunch, 400 euros
for a hospital room.
That's the connection
that we in our country
aren't making, is
that if we don't
feed our kids
healthy food today,
they're going to be in
the hospital in 10 years.
We already see that
the leading cause
of death of children
under 15 is cancer,
which is related to diet and
environment and exercise.
We know that one out
of every three kids
that was born in
the year 2000 is
going to be overweight
or diabetic.
It's crazy.
It's staggering.
Obesity in children has
tripled in 25 years.
I mean, it's a quarter
of a generation.
So things are going
bad so quickly
that we have to be able
to make the connection
between healthy food
and healthy kids.
And we have to be able to
push back on the bottom line
corporate mentality that is
pushing us in this direction.
It's not only going to ruin the
health of generations to come,
but it's going to bankrupt
the entire system.
We're not going to be able
to pay for it anymore.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you for coming.
Please talk to her some more.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]